how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we have some pretty crazy
spider-man 3
no way home news news that could confirm
that the spider-verse is indeed
happening in this film
and it looks like we have some pretty
good evidence today to support this
and i'll break down everything that you
need to know but first big announcement
for the premiere of the falcon and the
winter soldier that happened yesterday
i will be giving away two captain
america shields that are both
marvel legends shields giving away one
on youtube and
one on instagram for youtube all you
have to do is follow me
and my friend taya miller on youtube
i'll link her down below and the same on
instagram follow me on instagram and
follow her on instagram as well we'll be
picking a winner next
friday march 26th so today it appears
that andrew garfield's stunt double
william spencer was spotted on the set
of spider-man
no way home and he was spotted with tom
holland stunt double
greg townley now of course everybody is
freaking out because
why would andrew garfield stunt double
be with tom holland stunt double on the
set of a spider-man film one that is
heavily rumored to introduce the
spider-verse well of course the only
reason for this is because andrew
garfield is indeed
in spider-man no way home and his stunt
double is doing scenes with tom holland
stunt double because there will be
scenes with andrew garfield spider-man
and tom holland spider-man now we've had
reports that andrew garfield's
spider-man and toby mcguire spider-man
will indeed be in this film
it's already confirmed that jamie foxx's
elektra is going to be returning along
with alfred molina's
doctor octopus and these reports are all
from extremely
credible news outlets so we know that
something with the spider-verse
is happening but there is another
interesting part about this instagram
story today
the photos were actually taken down now
i did some research and they were indeed
posted to instagram some sites like the
direct actually linked the actual post
and now when you go look at it it's no
longer available because
it has been removed now the two of them
aren't actually pictured in the same
photo together but if you take a look at
what the caption of this photo says that
william spencer posted
it says challenge of the day with
stuntman
parkour boss man at bin jinx also
not pictured because he did the
challenge too fast to be filmed
at greg townley who is tom holland stunt
double force spider-man
so this is proof that the two of them
were just together he just was not
filmed
and since he had to take the post down
this is most likely what happened
he posted this and somebody either his
publicist or somebody from sony marvel
disney etc
saw this and they were like take that
down now it says that you were with
andrew garfield stuntman which is very
revealing but of course they don't count
on people on the internet being so quick
to snap screenshots so even though he
posted it and then took it down
a bunch of people took screenshots and
even linked the exact
post to some of their websites this
certainly does look like some good
evidence that andrew garfield is going
to be in spider-man no way home
this combined with the fact that tobey
maguire has been seen for various
outfit fittings and some other rumors
that andrew garfield was actually
spotted in a hotel in atlanta where the
film is shooting right now
it's looking pretty good that spider-man
3 no way home
could be the spider-verse movie that
we've all been waiting for and been
wanting
now of course this is just evidence it's
not actual proof yet so let's not get
our hopes too high
so we're not let down if it doesn't
actually happen but i will say that
things are actually starting to look
pretty good
especially if you do consider the fact
that spider-man no way home is supposed
to go into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which of course is
going to explore the multiverse but
hopefully the actual teaser trailer for
spider-man no way home is going to be
coming within the next few months and
we'll be able to find out
a little bit more information about the
spider-verse so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
3
no way home news and don't forget to
check the description down below for
details about the captain america shield
giveaway don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you